as an actor
how did that alter your approach you
know knowing that you're gonna have this
IMAX camera like right up in your face
I mean I'm a bit of a Nolan IMAX veteran
at this stage so I'm kind of used to it
but this was the most uh intense use or
kind of for the actors certainly of the
of the IMAX but again you just get used
to it you know you can't think like oh
this is going to be 80 foot or whatever
you you you can't think of it like that
I mean they make a terrific noise and
you soon get used to that but it becomes
just another another tool what I what I
couldn't I remember I'm done Kirk I
couldn't get over like hoyta would have
the the IMAX camera on his shoulder on
the boat uh
um so he's a phenomenal DP I think it
also makes a lot of difference when the
camera team
uh you get very close with the camera
team